ينضم الينا من خانيونس ايضا ومن طرف
المدينه تحديدا الدكتور محمد ابو مصبح
الناطق باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه ومدير الاسعاف والطوارئ اهلا بك
دكتور محمد كان معنا ايضا السيد رائد وكان
يتحدث عن انقطاع الاتصالات مع الكوادر
داخل خانيونس انت على اطراف المدينه ما
الذي
يجري بالتاكيد يعني مدينه خنيسي تتعرض
اساسا لهجمه شرسه منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
متواص ومدينه الامل تحديدا التابعه لليال
احمر الفلسطيني التي تحتوي على عدد كبير
من النازحين حوالي 10000 نازح بالاضافه
الى طواقم وكوادر مستشفى الامل التابع
للجمعيه ومركز الاسعاف فيها تعرض هذا
المبنى الى الاستهداف المباشر اكثر من
اربعه مرات وكان ضحيه هذه الاستهدافات 11
شهيدا بالاضافه الى 20 مصاب من النازحين
الان منذ ساعات الفجر تط وورت هذه الاحداث
الميدانيه لتصبح الطائرات المسيره المحمله
بال الاعيره الناريه واطلاق النار هي من
تسيطر على الاجواء وتمنع حركه سيارات
الاسعاف بشكل مباشر الاطلاق النار وا حركه
الاسعاف حجمت من خلال
هذه الاعيره الناريه المباشره في محيط
مركز الاسعاف طواقم مستشفى الامل على اهبه
الاستعداد لاستقبال نداءات المواطنين وك
نود الاشاره بان محافظه خانيونس لاكثر من
اسبوعين ينقطع فيها الاتصال تماما وهذا ما
يعقد عملنا ك طواقم الاسعاف في التواصل
الميداني قمنا بتوزيع عدد من مركبات
الاسعاف بشكل ميداني ومنتشره في اطراف
المدينه بالامس كانت خطوره هذه النقاط
تحديدا في محيط جامعه الاقصى غرب المحافظه
وخلف مستشفى ناصر هي اكثر عرضى ل طواقمنا
ل الخطر اعتقد بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تكرر نفس السيناريو الذي
عايشنا وشاهدنا في محافظه غزه عندما
اجبرت مستشفى القدس على الاخلاء قصرا
باتجاه الجنوب وهذه ستكون كارثه اكبر
وسيكون اثارها اكثر وخيمه على الشعب
الفلسطين لان المساحه المتاحه والتي يعتقد
بانها الاكثر امانا باتت ضيقه جدا لا
تحتوي ولا تستطيع ولا ولا يمكن ان تستوعب
هذا العدد من النازحين الفارين من الموت
الى الموت على ذكرى النازحين كان قبل قليل
مراسلنا اسماعيل ابو عمر يتحدث عن ان بعض
المواطنين يحاولون بالفعل الخروج من
خانيونس باتجاه رفح هل شاهدتم حركه نزوح
واضحه وانتم على اطراف
المدينه بالتاكيد نحن اي يعني قبل يومين
عدنا من محافظه غزه عندما كنا نا في طريق
لتقييم الحاله الانسانيه في غزه وشمالها
واعدنا خدمه الاسعاف هناك اعتقد بان الوضع
الانساني في قطاع غزه وتحديدا مع النازحين
في ظل النقص الشديد في المساعدات الخاصه
بالنازحين والمكونات الرئيسيه في الاواء
وصون كرامه هؤلاء الناس الذين تركوا
منازلهم مدمره
خلفهم باتت باتت منازلهم عباره عن قطع من
البلاستيك واخشاب يتم جمعها وو والعبث بها
شمالا ويمينا اعتقد بان المجتمع الدولي
يشاهد هذه المشاهد ويتابع و وبشكل متوالي
على النكبات المتواليه على ابناء شعبنا
النازحين في ظل هذا البرد الشديد والامطار
الشديده وهذا الموسم القار في البرد اعتقد
بان الاطفال باتت عليهم الامراض التي اي
هي ظاهره على الجهاز التنفسي النساء
الحوامل المسنين مرضى وال المزمنين
وانعدام العلاجات الخاصه بهم الوضع الخاص
بالمياه والاصحاح بشكل عام في قطاع غزه
والنظافه العامه القمامه التي لا يمكن
نقلها بسبب نقص الوقود لمركبات البلديه
والخدمات جميع هذه ال الكوارث والازمات س
ستنظر الاقليم بشكل كامل الى الى كوارث
واوبئه اعتقد ل لن يتم تحجيمها ولن يتم
استيعاب
بطرق او باخرى طيب الان وفق خبر عاجل عن
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني هناك انباء
عن عن وجود بلاغات بوجود شهداء ومصابين
جراء قصف اسرائيلي لمدرسه المواصي غرب خان
يونس حدثنا عن طبيعه المدرسه الذي بطبيعه
الحال انها تضم نازحين في هذا الوضع
الكارثي في خان يونس وما الذي توفر لديكم
المعلومات من خلال هذه
البلاغات بالتاكيد صحيح هذه المدرس فتم
فتحها واستيعاب عدد كبير من النازحين فيها
من خلال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بالتنسيق
مع وزاره التنميه عندما كان عدد النازحين
في مستشفى الامل يفوق قدرتها الاستيعابيه
وتم توفير بعض المستلزمات الغافيه لهم
فيها من خلال هذا المركز الذي لا يب لا
يبعد عن مستشفى الامل اقل من من واحد كيلو
متر باتجاه الغرب اعتقد بان هذه المدرسه
واستهدافها منذ اكثر من ثلاثه ساعات
نستقبل نداءات من المواطنين الذين ارتجلوا
مشيا على الاقدام الى مركز الاسعاف وفي
مخاطره على ارواحهم للتبليغ عن عدد من
الشهداء والاصابات ولكن عندما تتحرس
مركبات الاسعاف باتجاه هذه المدرسه يقوم
قوات الاحتلال من خلال الطائره المسيره
المحمله بالسلاح باطلاق النار بشكل مباشر
في محيط المركز الاسعاف هذا وقد قمنا
بالتواصل من خلال اللجنه الدوليه للصيب
الاحمر لاجراء تنسيق لدخول وصول امن الى
هذه المنطقه ولحتى اللحظه منذ اكثر من
ساعتين لا يمكن الحصول على رد او او ضوء
اخبر لتحرك مركبات الاسعاف وانا تحديدا
اخف على اطراف المدينه للدخول اليها وحتى
الان انتظر ضوء اخضر و وطرفه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منحنى هذا الضوء
الاخضر بل تعرض حياتنا و حياه كل المسعفين
والنازحين الى الخطر المباشر دون الاكتراث
لاي جهه دوليه او لاي من هذه المواثيق
التي حمت اشاره الهلال
وتجرم وتمنع وتحرم ان تمنع حركتنا وخدمتنا
الانسانيه في ظل هذا الوضع وهذا العدوان
على ابناء شعبنا ا طيب دكتور للتاكيد هل
هناك طواقم تابعه لكم لا تزال داخل خان
يونس وهل كان لدي لكم ايضا رصد لاستهداف
مباشره لطواقم
صحيح طواقمنا لا تزال جميعها تعمل في خن
يونس جميعها يعني طواقم مستشفى الامل
بكامل طاقمها وكادرها وهذا ما ما يزيد
العب على محافظه رفح باستقبال شهداء
واصابات مستشفى الامل قادر على استقبال
هذه الاصابات والشهداء من من محافظه خنيس
ولكن جميع الطرق هي تمنع و وتحول دون وصول
الاصابات اليها اليات قوات الاحتلال اما
عن الانتهاكات الخاصه ب طواقمنا فنحن وصل
عدد الشهداء من كوادرنا المسعفين الى اكثر
من تسعه من ضباط الاسعاف بجانب اكثر من 12
متطوعا و30 اصابه بين طواقمنا لا نزال نحن
كابناء شعبنا نتعرض الى هذه الانتهاكات
وحملنا قبل ذلك المسؤوليه الى جميع الجهات
الدوليه التي تمح ولا تزال تصمت على هذه
الانتهاكات بحق هذه الكوادر والطواقم شكرا
جزيلا لك من اطراف مدينه خانيونس الدكتور
محمد ابو نصبح الناطق باسم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه ومدير الاسعاف
والطوارئ